I think we all dream about
having those dates where it
feels like a movie.
Cole:
That was quite a date.
Things go well, but then he
screws everything up.
I sent Sadie one text today.
One.
And some light emoji stuff, but
that doesn't count.
Things just go downhill from
then on.
You have the wrong guy!
Who are you?
CIA.
Were you really gonna call me
when you got back?
Yes, until you texted me eleven
times in two days.
Emoji stuff doesn't count.
Emoji stuff counts.
Chris and Ana are so brilliant
at creating that connection.
I cannot believe you got me
kidnapped and tortured all after
one date!
Ana de Armas:
I was really looking forward to
working with Chris again,
Ana de Armas:
but in completely different
roles.
You're a liar. It's just lies and
lies and more lies.
It's not lies and more lies.
It's the sub-lie of the first
original lie.
You're unbelievable.
Ana is so effortlessly cool and
composed.
Chris Evans:
I've yet to see something she
can't do.
Are you ready?
Adrien Brody:
The scale of this is enormous.
So many moving pieces.
It's exciting.
Leveque:
If anything should go wrong...
Everyone dies.
The stakes are incredibly high.
It's just chemical weapons, and
bullets, and death.
But it's still rooted in
something authentic.
In my line of work it's better
being alone.
Cole:
Is it?
It's very charming, it has a big
heart.
Protecting the people you love
is never a mistake.
It's a story of taking a risk
outside of your comfort zone.
Chris Evans:
And how rewarding and refreshing
it can feel to wake up-
-and maybe not recognize
yourself.
Who the hell are you?
I'm the boyfriend.